- Hello, I'm Gav.
- I'm Dan.
Welcome to
"The Super Slow Show"--
Dan, we've done mousetraps.
- We've done mousetraps.
- We've done rat traps.
So what's bigger than a mouse
and bigger than a rat?
- Oh, a bear.
- A bear.
Right, okay, I see how
you've stepped up there.
So we've got a bear trap,
we've got the spin rig,
and we're gonna get
the hell over here
because this thing
terrifies me.
Yeah, I don't wanna get
annihilated by that arm.
- I'm just gonna go way...
- I'll follow your lead.
Yeah.
( theme music playing )
Curious to see
how powerful this is
against an actual bone,
an organically grown bone.
So its actual purpose,
then, basically,
rather than, like, things it's
not supposed to be crushing.
- Yeah, yeah, okay.
- Luckily I have a bone.
- Turkey leg.
- Yeah, well, a turkey leg.
Gav:
Imagine, if you will,
am entire turkey leg.
Ignore this part.
This is a turkey.
Who strayed into the forest.
For some reason,
it's already been marinated.
- Barbecue.
- All right, go for it.
Oh! Jeez, that is quick.
Good night, it's dripping.
Oh, it's juicy.
Let me just try to get
my leg out.
( grunting )
You can hear it.
The meat is squealing.
- That is--
- No, it's just not
gonna happen.
That is-- That you're not
getting out of that.
I think we've
demonstrated successfully
the power of this bear trap.
Yeah, for sure.
You know,
I got the dream of drams.
Put these on.
Doubt they're gonna help you,
but all right.
Well, you know.
- Let's start the spinner.
- Spinner up.
( whirring )
What if you were hit
by that thing?
- Like being hit by a car.
- God.
Orange soda--
all ready to go.
Loaded up.
That thing is hauling now.
- Dan: Ready?
- Cameras on.
I'm gonna have to time it.
And... now.
- Ooh.
- Nailed it.
- Oooh, flip.
- Lovely little puff.
Gav: Poor thing doesn't know
what's about to happen to it.
Dan: Here we go.
Here's impact.
Ready...
- Dan: Ooh.
- Gav: That looks lovely.
Looks like bullet-time
orange soda.
- Very hypnotizing.
- Dan: Yeah.
Dan:
It reaches the apex,
and then it's just floating.
Just got balls floating.
They are so weird.
And then you've got the air
sort of coming up
under some of these globules.
- Oh, look at that.
- The globs are really
far apart.
You can really tell the spin.
That's amazing.
I like it when there's--
Oh, there's us.
Oh, I didn't wave.
I meant to wave.
You had a lot to think about.
I did, yeah.
Let's go for a reset.
So I've only ever seen
these bear traps in cartoons,
where they, like, get a stick
and they test it or whatever.
It just looks so terrifying.
It just looks like something
nobody should be near.
Well, I'm used to setting
mousetraps, right?
So this is definitely--
I'm even sure
I can watch it.
Are you sure
you're doing it right?
'Cause it looks brutal.
- It is.
- Like, I'm already picturing
a gruesome...
Right, so this gets lifted.
- Okay.
- All right, good.
- And now it's set.
- All right...
- Now we can--
- Don't put your head in it.
That's got about
6 to 900 pounds
of pressure,
which is about the same
as a bear's jaw.
Do you get
the irony of it?
Yeah. The tension
on that is beefy.
- Yeah.
- Which is pretty cool.
And the tension between us...
I bet a bear trap would eat
two cans of paint.
- Yeah?
- Eat 'em right up.
- For breakfast?
- Right.
- Well, let's find out.
You ready?
- Yeah.
Three, two, one...
( hissing )
- Oh.
- Ooh.
I got orange, right?
Purple was the other one.
Yep, purple and orange.
It was a Rimmy Tim.
Just sort of chewed it open.
Didn't it?
Just floating-- paint cans.
Gav:
It's so surreal, this footage.
- Dan: Oh...
- Gav: Man.
Dan:
Just gets eaten...
Gav: It's cool
how you see a thick paint
in the middle and it's misting
at the side of it.
On to the next thing?
Why don't we do something solid,
something that will shatter?
Ooh.
I've got a mirror loaded,
one by one foot.
Camera's hauling ass.
- Is... pretty--
- Okay, I'm gonna drop.
Now!
Now.
( together )
Oh!
- Success.
- Devastating mess.
What I'm glad about
is that it shattered
into loads of pieces,
rather than just, like,
four pieces.
That's just
what I was after.
Oh, there's us.
Here it comes.
Oh...
( both imitate shattering )
Gav: Lovely.
That's cool.
Pretty good, eh?
Spitting bits of glass
going everywhere.
Lovely glittering mess.
Dan: Look at that.
Good variety of things
been chomped there.
Yeah, I think one
of the scariest moments
from anything
we've ever filmed
was watching you
put your hand in a bear trap.
I know you were
just setting it, but--
Do you know what I did?
I enjoyed having my hand
in there
and watching your face
just be like ( groans ).
I'm glad.
I'm glad you got--
And you get enjoyment
from me worrying about you.
That's the last time I'm
worrying about you from now on.
Oh, come on.
Well, this is what it would've
done to my arm anyway.
Look at the state of this?
Would've made a mess of a leg.
That's one of the teeth
from the bear trap,
just chomping in there.
One of my favorite things we
chucked in there was the mirror.
- Oh, yeah.
- Just all the smashed glass
'cause the tiny pieces
kept reflecting stuff.
It was like a deconstructed
disco ball
spinning around.
- Well done.
Good, good, yeah.
- Thank you.
Well, I hope
you enjoyed that,
and we'll see you
in the next video.
- There was sumo wrestling.
- The magnet smash.
- The ice sculpture explosion.
- Three-stone smash.
Yeah, that was really messy.
I wonder.
What's your favorite?